[Music]
hey guys it's benefits of a G from G
tracker here and in this video I'm going
to be talking about game updates but
first off I wanted to apologize to you
guys in the fact that this video is a
little bit over a week since the last
video I released I try and release a
video every single week um but the video
I worked on last week didn't hold up to
the standards that I wanted all of our
videos to hold up to so I eventually
deleted that one alt together and worked
on a new topic which is the one that I'm
talking about now so in this video I'm
going to be talking about the potential
impacts that a Dev Q&A and game updates
have to the economy and what you should
be looking for as a merchant or just as
a player and how you should interact
with these
changes so before I go over some charts
um the the first thing I wanted to bring
up is if you watched my last video or
one of my previous videos on the
different types of merchants you would
have learned that paying attention to
q&as is one of the fundamental keys to
success as a merchant because one of the
things you want to do or at least one of
the tools you want to have under your
skill set is being able to predict price
changes before they happen so obviously
Dev Dev q&as would be the key factor for
predicting item changes um I'm not going
to talk about Q&A specifically in this
video but rather their impact to the
item and then the
aftermath so if you guys look at the
upper part of the screen here you'll
notice I have quite a bit of tabs open
that's because I want to go over a few
items to give you guys a real sense that
these updates and q&as do have a real
impact to the market and overall economy
so if you want to take yourself
seriously as a merchant this is
something not to ignore so when we go
over the first item it's going to be
Mony monkey Madness 2 which was released
on May 5th
2016 now with monkey Madness they were
going to introduce some best and Slot
gear which were basically zenite
jewelry and in order to obtain zenite
jewelry you had to kill demonic gorillas
so basically this was a pvm update and
when you think about a pvm update
they're going to be merchants and the
overall Community trying to invest in
items they believe are going to be
useful for killing these for killing
these
off now when we look at the toxic bloke
pipe and we look around the same time
frame now keep in mind um I'm looking at
the yearly time frame so these dates
aren't going to be exactly um on the
date of the release but if we look
previously um the price had basically
almost skyrocketed to almost a million
um above its original price when this
came out so obviously this had a real
impact and thinking as a player you have
to you have to think at a certain point
um if you did miss out on this and
didn't invest in this are you going to
continue buying this item at this price
and if so are you willing to lose money
on it when it goes back down I say that
for an obvious reason because most of
these items do decrease in value after
their initial Spike and so when you're
looking at these graphs when you're
trying to flip these and I've I've told
you before that you want to look at
historic lows and Highs but you have to
take in consideration the updates
themselves and why they might have
played a role in the actual price of
those items so if you look at the
blowpipe here we can notice that it was
at 3 million 3.5 million for quite some
time for a few months actually until it
started to decrease quite rapidly um
back to a million loss in value um so
that's something to keep in mind and
next we have the dragon Warhammer which
was released on the 21st of January
2016 now this was also a pvm update and
people initially thought I wouldn't say
everyone but a good portion of the
community believed that this item was
going to be very useful for PVP because
if we look at this special attack here
it says the dragon Warhammer reduces the
defense of your opponent by 30% of their
current Defense level if you hit if your
hit is successful and increases the
damage doubt by
50% initially people believe that this
would be great for pking but you can't
think like the community if the
community says one thing it doesn't mean
that it's a finite reason or it's not
set in stone um for example if you guys
remember when links Titan released the
kuram store video everyone started to
freak freak out like holy crap this is
op why is this even in
game well before he ever released that
video he wasn't the only one using it um
so clearly thinking like the community
isn't going to provide any kind of
success or give you an edge you always
want to provide yourself um you always
want to think for yourself so you guys
can give yourself those edges um all the
time so if we by just reviewing this
special attack
we know that one of the most useful
things um would be to use this on
Corporal Beast which has a very high
Defense level and it's one of the most
popular NPCs to kill for money obviously
the Elijah Spirit Shield is a
significant amount of money even though
it's kind of hitting a spotty area right
now it's still a lot of money and anyone
getting that drop is going to make
absolute bank so if we look at the
dragon Warhammer
here um I don't remember exactly what
this price was on release but I believe
it was around 70 or 80ish mil um on
release and it was like that for a
little bit but when people started to
talk about it in the sense that it
wasn't useful for bking anymore and
people started using it in bking videos
and it showed to kind of like not live
up to their standards it kind of uh
declined quite rapidly and hit I believe
um 40 million this is only showing like
50 million but this isn't going back to
the day of release um so there was a
couple of days in between where um this
might have gone down a little bit even
further than what it was
previously but then people started to
quickly realize that you know just like
I said it was useful for corpor beast
and all of a sudden it started to
increase quite rapidly and then now we
have our more stable price of around
75ish to 80ish mil um so it's kind of
flatlined so that's another update to
kind of pay attention to If an item
comes into the game and the community
looks at it in one way is that item
useful significantly in another fashion
and if so do you believe that it's
current price point should is
undervalued than what it should be in
the future when other people start to
realize this and the whole Community
kind of goes on board so next we have
dragon spear change and this is
different from the previous one ones in
which the previous two were updates to
the game um introducing new items
whereas this one was a Nerf which is
still something you guys should pay
attention to for obvious reasons now if
you guys didn't know before the change
basically the dragon spear was so op
that if you were in multi-weight combat
and a team came to you with this um and
they all use them they could all stack
up the special attack which would
basically basically stun you and you
couldn't eat drink uh drink prayer
potion or teleport um you're basically a
Sitting Duck waiting to die uh so that
was that was a special attack previously
to the update but now with the new
update you can no longer use these
special attacks to stack up on on one
another so if someone's already stunned
another one of your teammates can't come
and use their special attack on him
while he's done to prevent him from un
stunning so basically now this gives
players the opportunity to drink prayer
potions eat or teleport giving them a
one tick Community after a stun in which
they can try and
Escape so obviously this is kind of this
is a huge change um the dragon spear had
a significant use in the pan Community
for big Clans for this obvious reason
you'd go into deep Wilderness
multi-weight combat you'd have 20 of
these guys using these special attacks
and your victim virtually can't do
anything they're just they're just dead
basically um so keep in mind before I go
over the graph though that this was in
discussion prior to this blog coming out
so players already knew that this Nerf
was coming so this plays into the whole
um paying attention to q&as and Reddit
post um if you see the community trying
to discuss kind of like nerfing a
certain item and the mods are in
agreement of this saying that you know
yeah this is op and we need to make sure
that it's not it's not so overpowered
and it needs a Nerf then those should be
uh alarm Bells going off in your head
that this item is more than likely going
to lose a significant amount of its
original
value so keeping that in mind we know
that this blog was already well known
before it came out um so July
28th okay so we have here the drop off
happened off basically a month
before more than a month before the
update um came into the game so it was
sitting around like 70ish 80ish k um and
then all of a sudden when this was
significantly talked about in the mods
we're in agreement of Nerf this we can
see that it dropped in price
significantly way before the update
actually happened um by the time it
actually came into the game it was
already it already settled to its price
point while before while before that um
so that's something to keep in mind as
well if for whatever reason you're
holding on to an item I don't know why
it'd hold on to like a 100 Dragon Spears
but you know other items if you're if
you're investing in an item you're
hoarding some items for a long-term
investment and you notice that the
community is talking about this being
nerfed and then you see that the jods
earn agreement of this like say twitch
um then this is something that you might
want to sell off but keep in mind you
don't want to you don't want to base
those judgments based on you know kind
of like a casual oh yeah that I think
that is a little op you want to base
them off of a strong incentive from the
mods to Nerf this uh the difference is
when they were talking about the dragon
spear this was like yeah this is a set
in stone we're nerfing this this is
definitely op we're not keeping this
anymore like the community already knew
this was happening for a fact there was
no there was no judgment on whether or
not this wasn't coming um so that's the
difference speculation versus uh the J
Mod's actually saying yeah this is
definitely something that's going to
come to the game expect it coming soon
um in which case then you would of
course want to sell it off
next we have the P update now this is a
Blog that was that was introduced to the
public a while before the update
actually happened now if we scroll down
here we'll actually see when this was
introduced um this was around June 17th
but they were already talking about this
well before this blog was updated or
well before this blog was released to
the public um so we have June 17th when
there was an official blog on this
and then we have the update itself which
was um August 25th okay so a couple
months later um so with this kind of
update this kind of plays the opposite
effect of the Dragon spear change the
dragon spear change was a Nerf whereas
this update makes the items used for
this more useful more valuable for a
certain period of time
um you have to realize with these kind
of
updates it almost always happens almost
always um the community sees this update
they see the the that this is coming
into the game then everyone I well again
I wouldn't say everyone but a good
portion of the community starts to hoard
up these items in an anticipation of
this update um and then with that mass
movement of players and in in these
items they are all artificially
inflating the price which is increasing
that price of that item and I don't know
if people I don't know um if people are
blindly not realizing that that's being
artificially inflated or they're just
kind of like ignoring it and just kind
of enjoying the fact that they've all
increased the price um
simultaneously um I say that because
sometimes I see
players come in to
come into the Discord chat very late
with these kind of updates for example
when raids was updated into the game or
before raids was updated like a week or
two weeks before players were asking
what type of items they should have
tried investing in um which is which is
way too late by that time it's it's done
I mean you already missed the mass
movement you already missed the mass
inflation of those items and by
investing so close to the actual release
date you're putting yourself at risk for
losing money which I'm going to go over
in a little bit so obviously with
construction um the two main useful
items for this would be Oak and mahogany
planks so if we look at mahogany plants
okay so we have August 25th of when this
um expansion actually came into the game
and we have around June when they
started talking about this okay so
around June we can see that this price
started to increase in price we noticed
that around May um the the mods probably
were talking about this a little bit and
then they released that blog and then
all of a sudden it's increased in price
quite
significantly um after it became
official that this was going to come
into the game everyone well again not
everyone but a good portion of the
community wanted to buy this item thus
officially inflated in the price of this
item and so you have it that this price
um is now much higher than it normally
would have been without it um so let's
go ahead and back and look at when this
was actually released so if August
25th
um August
25th okay so around August we can see
that for a little bit the price remained
at its price point but then obviously
everyone wanted to start dumbing their
items and then the price started to go
back down um it took a little bit of
time for this to go significantly down
in price because there are a few wealthy
players in game that want to use this um
but again over time obviously this item
is going to start declining in price
back to its original price points or
maybe it's going to stay um maybe this
is its new price point maybe 2000 is
going to be the new stable price of this
item as opposed to
1,700 but if you've missed the wave of
this in of this Mass hype
investment it's probably not a good idea
to invest in this item um once you've
already missed this big spike you've
already missed that huge Cash Cow um
it's I mean it's already gone other than
that your margins are going to be pretty
thin and by that point you can you can
just start flipping items items normally
like you normally would um like every
day uh this these these should be like
investment type opportunities where you
see these massive spikes um you want to
be an early bird to these Investments
and then once it hits this price once it
hits its peak then that's usually around
the time you want to start selling off a
good portion of them maybe not all of
them um but closer to the release date
you certainly want to release more of
those items and then once the release
date comes um if you haven't done so
already then you should be hurrying up
to the GE to get rid of them because
they're going to go back in back down in
price again
soon so next we have winter dot this was
a scaling update to the game in which uh
the mods wanted to make fire making a
little bit less tedious than just kind
of burning logs and a little bit more I
guess you would say fun um to train in
game and this one one's a little bit
harder to predict price changes uh
because we don't know exactly what was
going to be released in game what the
loot was going to look like um but you
can certainly try and if you were like
one of the first players to play the
game like on the first day then you can
obviously get a feel for some items that
might have lost their value um but yeah
so as we can see there's more of this
coming into the game than there is
people wanting to buy this
and if we look at this uh yearly time
frame we don't even need to look at the
uh the time of when this was released in
the blog because on our charts we now
have it where if you look at the labels
little letters I guess you would say
there's a little label that um will tell
you what the update was in game uh for
that day so basically ever since ever
since this was implemented into the
charts with all all um Dev blog post we
have them automatically attached to the
Chart um so um you can also you can
obviously hide them if you don't want to
see them so if it's a little bit too
cluttered for you you can click hide or
you can click show them if you want to
and another neat feature is if you want
to click on this you can click on it and
it'll take you to that exact blog of the
update itself so you can get a little
bit more information on that back into
this item we can see that when before
winter dot was released this was at a
stable like like above 2K really but
ever since this update came into the
game um the price of this has
declined significantly um very
significantly actually and now it's at a
price point in which it's not even like
it's not even worth picking up well I
guess if you were a free-to-play player
you would pick this up because you're
kind of like going anyway that you can
possibly get
but obviously this is a massive change
and it obviously hurts the freet to-play
community so if you had this item stored
up you were hoarding it flipping it or
for whatever reason obviously you didn't
want to hold it on for much longer and
if you saw it to incre decrease in price
um this is obviously a couple days in
between but if you started to see it
decrease in price um before this for
this date then obviously this should
have been like a little bit of a warning
B for you to get rid of this item and
not hold on to it so like if you had
20,000 of these and you were trying to
flip them you wouldn't have lost a lot
of money from when it goes down so
that's another update to pay attention
to uh this is kind of this is almost
like a Nerf I wouldn't say it was a Nerf
um it wasn't meant to be but it does
certainly hurt the value of this item so
one thing to pay attention to updates
would be if there's a loot table for
from that uh boss or whatever miname
that come into the game is it a
significant amount that it would hurt
the value of this
item and finally we have the chambers of
zerich update uh this was a much
anticipated update to the game uh for
obvious reasons there were quite a bit
of uh drops from this uh raid that were
definitely that definitely had the
community's eyes on them uh for example
the two-handed uh Shield was one of them
because it had an impact on the value of
the lives and spirit Shield which is
hitting a spotty area right now and then
obviously the Twisted bow which is at
the time of this video over a billion uh
worth so if you were to get that drop in
raids then you've made absolute Bank um
but with this update again like all
premium updates so just like monkey
Madness players are going to want to
kind of hoard up items that they believe
are going to be most efficient for
killing these
bosses um so one of these items that
turned out to be quite useful was the
arams robe top um so we have it here
that raids was released on January 25th
and we can see the price has gone up a
little bit more than its current than
its current value uh previously so it
was a little it was I remember it wasn't
this uh let's see here yeah so it wasn't
it wasn't that price
beforehand um but over time as players
started to uh wanted to kind of like
invest in items that were going to be
more useful for raids this obviously
would have been something that maybe
they would have thought that would have
been really useful for um this kind of
update and then more and then obviously
um when this update came into the game
when people saw it it was actually
useful instead of decreasing in price
right away um it kind of kept its price
point for a little bit um and then kind
of slowly went back down if you um if
you look at the picture that I use in
the screenshot for the YouTube video you
can see here that basically everyone
well everyone is actually using void uh
as their gear of choice so obviously the
reason for using void would be that you
save inventory space for supplies so
then that would make this not as useful
as it was for when it was initially in
introduced into the game um and then
players learned how to actually um
defeat the raids boss uh and then
obviously this is going to kind of go
down in price um because it's not as
useful as it was when it was released on
update
but opposed to that another item that
kept its use if you if you look at this
picture here is the Arcane Spirit Shield
um the Arcane Spirit Shield was mainly
used for killing zor
um obviously you want to have a higher
DPS so you can kill bosses in a in a
quicker fashion um so you can get more
money per hour so that was mainly used
for Zora but with the introduced
introduction of raids now it's useful as
well for raids um so if we look at that
um if we look at the timely time graph
here um at one point in time it hit a
pretty significant price point
previously um um and it was kind of like
in the 70ish mill for a long time um had
this little Spike but then it went back
down quite rapidly uh soon after um and
then with the raids update um it didn't
hit its Spike until basically the day of
um and then if we look at a closer time
frame we can see that um on this update
it basically just kind of skyrocketed
from that point from that point on um
and now it's basically almost like
almost 100 million now so basically
getting a significant increase in value
um so if you were to do raids on day one
and you're a wealthy Merchant then
obviously maybe this is something that
you would want would have wanted to
hoard up realizing that this is
something that would have been very
useful in completing raids in uh a
quicker fashion because on day one
people were doing raids in like 3 hours
um it was it was pretty bad now players
are getting it under like 30 minutes to
like 40 minutes are like the average
times now with like maxed with maxed out
players um so obviously this is another
item to look at um you have one item
that seemingly would have been useful
for raids um increased in price pretty
significantly obviously it didn't keep
its price point because void was the
better option for this um
and then it's Lo it lost its price
points a lot sooner than the Arcane
Spirit shield and I'm not going to go
into the fact of whether or not this is
going to keep its price or it's going to
continue increasing in price or go down
in price that's all up to you guys um
but another one another item I want to
go over real quick um didn't actually
save it on here but why don't we look at
the Sarah doen Brew because o
Sarah doen sarahan
Brew okay so obviously with
raids you would have wanted to last as
long as possible without dying because
every time you die you actually lose
some points which affects your loot
reward so obviously you want to have the
most amount of points so you can get the
best possible
reward um so if we look at this here if
we look at the yearly time frame we can
see that um um at one point in time this
increased in price pretty significantly
uh for whatever reason I guess the
community felt like okay this is a good
time to start investing rates coming up
pretty soon probably around the time
when they started doing more YouTube
videos on it so around the time they
started talking about raids a little bit
more is probably the time that they
started um people started investing in
this so you can see here that the price
point was around like 3 or 4K and then
all of a sudden it's started to increase
in price pretty significantly and it's
kind of keeping that price now um so
raids and basically updates in general
can influence the price of an item
either negatively or positively and it's
up to you guys to determine whether or
not those items are going to be useful
in the long run or whether or not that's
just kind of like an artificial
inflation and that price is going to go
down over time seeing as it's not as
useful as um it should be so another
item that was inflated because of raids
was the dragon fire Shield but it
decreased in price when players realized
that it wasn't as useful um so basically
artificially
inflated so let's look at this here um
so initially it was around 12 million
then as raids became closer and closer
people started investing it quite
heavily and then all of a sudden it hit
like 17 mil and then after raids was
released it just dropped right back
again so those are two key key
distinctions when you're making these
Investments you have to try and predict
whether or not these are going to be
long-term uses for these updates um
obviously pay attention to q&as and see
if um like if if a Q&A or Reddit post is
going to impact the price of an item by
nerfing it and then obviously um again
if the community is looking at one item
and it's not being looked at in another
way so with the dragon Warhammer players
were looking at it as a ping item was it
useful in another fashion um I know this
was a long video guys but I wanted to
give a clear picture as to basically any
kind of update that you guys might face
so give you guys that solid foundation
so when these things come into the game
you guys can be a little bit more
prepared on how you guys should think
about this and how you guys should view
it so real quick before I go guys um I
wanted to showcase our last old school
RuneScape Bond winner from our uh
giveaway from like a month ago um it
took a while for me to contact this guy
but we finally got it done um I'm going
to go ahead and leave a link in the
description down below um showing a
video that shows all the other winners
so you guys can look that if you want to
I mean it's just kind of like music and
me giving them the bonds there's really
nothing there like information wise um
but if you guys were looking at the top
of the screen you would have noticed
this little uh blue box here and it's
basically a little Poll for you guys um
we're releasing a form pretty soon um
not yet we're still working on it um but
we want you guys to vote on what you
guys wanted to look like um so we
created a little Google uh Forum Poll
for you guys in which we showcase some
of the different themes for you guys to
vote on um obviously it's a single
Choice answer but you guys can
definitely vote on what you guys would
like to see um for our forums this has
kind of been something that's been asked
about all the time um so we're finally
bringing it to you guys and you guys
definitely have the voice to decide what
it should be um that's going to be end
of the video guys if you guys like this
video be sure to leave a like down below
to show your support leave a comment
letting me know uh any kind of videos
you guys want to see in the future be
sure to subscribe good luck Merchant
guys until next
time
oh